il y en a marre il y en a marre avec
l'agriculture je pense qu'en France on
se rend pas compte que ils sont tous en
train de crever les uns après les autres
et ça c'est insupportable il y en a
marre de voir arriver des poulets
brésiliens pendant que vous nêes pendant
que vous ne pou dans le même temps vous
n'arrivez pas à vendre tous vos bons
produits on a la meilleure agriculture
de France moi je veux bien que ce soit
triste de bloquer la France mais enfin
ça va il y a un moment donné où il faut
les aider il faut probablement faire du
protectionnisme sur tous les produits
français parce que c'est insupportable
de savoir que tel fromage disparaît
qu'on est obligé de que vous que vous
êtes obligé parfois d'exporter à un prix
dérisoire que vous savez même pas
combien vous êtes payé moi franchement
c'est que le le la dictature des écolos
à un moment donné il va falloir aussi
qu'on ouvre le débat ça fait des années
que les écolos disent n'importe quoi
avec notamment les pesticides avec
notamment des relais de d'opinion sur
dans tous les médias qui disent
absolument tout et n'importe quoi
notamment sur le glyphosate qui
contrairement à l'espèce de musique
répandue dans toute la France France n'a
encore tué personne sauf deux individus
dont un qui était couvert de glyphosate
je le sais puisque j'ai fait son
interview en Argentine il y a 5 ans donc
tout ce qu'on dit est totalement faux et
pendant ce temps-là vous vous crevez
alors moi je suis désolé mais des
barrages des trucs qui brûlent les
infirmiers et cetera moi aussi j'ai de
la compassion pour eux mais franchement
on est en train de flinguer notre
agriculture qu'est-ce qui va se passer
dans 10 ans les deux traités
internationaux mais on autorise de la
viande de merde on autorise des poulet
dégueulasse c'est ça qu'on donne et puis
il y a le scandale et puis il y a le
scandale des hypermarchés exactement ça
dites-le parce que ça mais le scandal
des hypermarchés c'est qu'on a créé
trois lois des lois qui s'appellent
égalim et vous allez dire ce que vous en
pensez qui sont censés qui étaient
censés faire en sorte qu'on vous protège
un petit peu que vous ayez une toute
petite part du gâteau pourquoi il y a
une solution très simple pourquoi quand
on va acheter son paquet de pâtes ou en
tous les cas des légumes on nous dit pas
quelle est la part qui revient à
l'agriculteur et la part qui revient au
transformateurs à ceux qui font la
distribution et au distributeurs je
voulais dire les intermédiaires mais
mais les de tiers vont à d'autres gens
qu'aux agriculteurs enfin mais c'est
hallucinant un petit truc c'est que
Gabriel le Premier ministre a maintenu
l'idée que les Français devaient cons en
majorité des produits provenant de leur
pays mais comme jeai dit la dernière
fois bien
s aujourd'hui un poulet sur de qui est
consommé en France n'est pas français
comment il comment voulez qu' non mais
comment tu veux comment tu veux
aujourd'hui consommer français ce que je
disais la dernière fois disait les mecs
allez faire les courses je dis voilà k
de pomme 380 ou un kil de pomme 12 je tu
sais pas si elles viennent d'Ukraine de
polne de tombouou voilà mais tu te dis B
elles sont à 12 voilà c'est tout mais
aujourd'hui c'est bien marrant de dire
consommer français moi il faut il faut
que il faut que les Français battent
avec les mêmes armes que les autres Gill
je vais me tourner vers toi et je je
vais je vais être sympa avec toi mais je
vais te dire un truc non mais non mais
je vais te dire un truc non je vais te
dire un truc parce que je te vois mettre
la pancartte oui et c'est tout tout tout
ton
paradoxe tu es le premier à défendre
toutes les
mesures
complètement desuettes des écologiste et
ce qu' vient de dire Jacques Cardo je
suis d'accord avec lui à 100 %. problème
Gilles Verdez à un moment c'est ton
problème c'est qu'un moment tu peux pas
défendre tout le monde soit tu es avec
eux soit tu es cont ex je vais te dire
et à un moment tu peux pas aujourd'hui
ne crois pas aujourd'hui on est tous
bien sûr on est tous soucieux de notre
planète et les agriculteurs les premiers
et je vais te dire les agriculteurs je
peux te dire c'est c'est c'est
exactement ils font plus que nous ils
font plus que nous tous ici autour de la
table et bien plus que toi voilà je te
le dis mais à un moment il y a des
priorités et toi à un moment ch je te le
dis à un moment quand tu vois toutes les
actions qui sont faites et tout ce qui
est demandé par tes amis c'est pas mes
amis he c'est tes amis c'est tes amis
tous ceux qui font du mal sont tes
amis voilà comme ça c'est simple
j'imagine que sur Saint Soline par
exemple oui non mais c'est un exemple il
faut qu'on fasse comprendre peê
l'istoire elle est tout simple c'est une
question de rétention d'eau c'est la
problématique des rétention d'eau non
mais il y a Monsieur l'agriculteur qui
connait forcément mieux le la
problématique que moi mais on était dans
quelque chose qui était très idéologique
à savoir on est contre cette histoire de
de rétention d'eau et donc il y a eu
s Greff tout un mouvement écolo
radical tu les soutiens ces gensl mais
moi je suis du côté des agriculteurs là
c'est oui
massif tu dis bien comment comment tu
fais a tes amiscol mais c'est pas mes
amis moi je suis du côté des
agriculteurs je moi ce que je défends ce
sont les actions écolo pour améliorer la
vie de la planète mais je suis pas
débile là vous avez de l'urgence quand
pour taer une e il y a 14 normes qu'on
donne aux agriculteurs c'est débile
d'ailleurs monsieur hata l' a dit ce
soir on va revenir à une n ils sont
englués je les connais par cœur ils sont
englués il y a une injustice on achète
des produits en Pologne au Portugal ils
ne peuvent plus vivre de leur travail
comment vous voulez-vous mettre en
opposition avec ça Cyril moi je suis
pour que la planète soit propre mais je
suis pour qu'on sauve l'agriculture il y
a des urgences et je trouve qu'il y a
toujours des solutions de compromis à
trouver et là c'est bien l'urgence c'est
sauver
l'agriculture aujourd'hui pour moi il y
a aucun compromis ok j' je te dis il y a
pas de compromis les compromis là les
compromis on aurait dit oui il y a 10
ans là aujourd'hui il y a plus on a plus
le temps il y a plus de temps a on est
est plus dans les compromis il y a une
urgence c'est tous les jours qui passe
tu as un agriculteur qui qui veut
suicider ou qui arrive pas à manger ou
qui arrive pas à nourrir sa famille ou
qui arrive pas et qui en peut plus donc
aujourd'hui c'est tous les jours qui
passe c'est pas c'est pas on dit on a le
temps sera dans 6 mois dans 3 mois non
c'est là maintenant c'est tout de suite
c'est demain que ils doivent pouvoir
être se battre avec les mêmes armes que
les autres
parce que l'Europe l'Europe c'est bien
sympa on nous sort toujours l'Europe
quand il y a des problèmes on dit ah
mais non c'est l'Europe là c'est
Bruxelles on peut pas Bruxelles ils ont
dit sinon ils vont nous défoncer mais là
le problème c'est que l'Europe bien sûr
qu'elle a sa part mais le truc c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous non seulement il y a
des contraintes de l'Europe mais nous on
en rajoute derrière 4000 il y a 400000
normesil 400000 normes plus 300000
agriculurs c'est pas mal il y a plus de
normes
d'agricon a plus d'une norme chacun
c'est pas mal comme des émissions de TF1
il y a plus d'argent que du gens qui
regardent certaines émissions c'est fou
je te jure c'est incroyable oui oui ah
non mais je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec Jacques avec toi ils sont à la base
de notre alimentation mais sans vous on
ne peut on ne mange pas vraiment et donc
moi je soutiens à 1000 % ces actions je
sais que ça embête des personnes qui
vont partir au travail sembê beaucoup de
monde mais comme tu l'as dit c'est c'est
c'est une urgence c'est une urgence les
les agriculteurs les éleveurs sont pris
à la gorge avec tout le travail qu'il
fournit ce travail mais je sais il Nick
jado là qui était sur BFM
là il vient de dire qu' qu'il était au
côté des agriculteurs mais comment il
dire ça mais je vous jure mais mais les
mecs mais moi je veux bien mais mais les
mecs on entend ces conneries mais moment
un moment donné on peut pas se cacher
derrière ce qu'on a déjà dit non mais
c'est ça un moment tu peux pas leur
mettre des bâtons dans les roues toute
la journée et leur dire oui non mais non
je suis avec toi je suis fond avec toi
je te soutiens par contre je vais te
rajouter une norme là en fait tu vas pas
pouvoir non mais non mais les gars non
mais non mais en fait tes amis au c'est
pas mes amis si c'est tes amis
il fait partie de tes amis je suis
désolé ils osent tout tes amis osent
tout arrête avec eux oui vraiment c'est
c'est surtout quand quand on parle de
l'écologie les premiers concernés par
l'écologie qui travaillent avec la météo
c'est quand même les agriculteurs donc
eux s'ils sont concernés par des
règlements climatiques c'est quand même
les eux les premiers concernés à
travailler avec la météo après quand je
les vois bloquer moi j'étais bloqué vous
avez bloqué la 13ise à côté du village
des marqu vous m'avez fait sortir de
l'autoroute hier mais ça m'a pas dérangé
en fait non mais parce que toi c'était
vraiment pour toi ils peuvent pas te
blérer non on savait que vous passiez
désolé
en plus là pour le coup c'est de ma
faute c'est moi qui a lancé cette
manifestation ton itinéire j'ai tu me le
fous de côé tu vois tu m'as bloqué hier
sur la 13 et je m'en fous parce que je
me dis que j'aimerais bien comme dit
Cyril j'aimerais bien que en France
quand tu travailles tu sois récompensé
de ton travail vous êtes tout le temps
en train de parler des pays comment ça
se passe ailleurs on est le pays le plus
imposable le pays le plus imposé au
monde pas de l'Europe he du monde
peut-être il y a le Danemark devant nous
mais sinon la Belgique aussi beaucoup
imposé mais sur le travail on est les
champions du monde en Allemagne il P il
paye moins d'impôts sur le travail le
travail est moins taxé ailleurs et je
vous dis je me dis que la France a
beaucoup de chance que les autres
artisans ne viennent pas se joindre à
votre mouvement parce que vous vous
pouvez bloquer avec les les tracteur les
les routiers ils peuvent bloquer avec
les camions la SNCF il nous bloque avec
les trains souvenez-vous l'histoire de
l'essence contre les cordonniers vont
pas bloquer avec des ch que je
disoireessence vendu souvenez-vous
souvenez-vous l'histoire de l'essence
quand j'avais tapé un petit coup de
gueule j'avais dit là ils se battent
pour eux et pas pour le prix de
l'essence non c'est pas vrai ils se
battent pour le prix de l'essence ils se
battaient pour eux parce qu'ils avaient
déjà des des salaires bien et là la SNF
c'est pareil quand ils se battent c'est
pour eu moi j'aimerais bien que la
France elle se dise voilà un moment
donné il y a les agriculteurs vous vivez
pas de votre travail c'est pas pour
jouer là j'entends Daniel qui dit ouis
ils vont monter à Paris ils menacent ils
sont déjà montés à
Paris
Paris mon quelqu
temps bien dire Gabriel au gouvernement
ils sont pas en train de jouer parce que
moi quand jeis r Gabri vient d'arriver
j'ai l'impression qu'il est train de
bouger bouge par que ils ont prévenu
j'ai je me dis j'ai j'ai un petit espoir
parce que ça j boug jusquà prés il est
là il est tout neuf il vient d'arriver
et on lui fait déjà une petite
manifestation c'est peut-être votre
chance aussi peut-être qu'il va bouger
assez vite il a dit qu'il allait bouger
assez vite moi je pense que demain
j'espère bien qu'il vienneent vous voir
il en est capable je pense qu' et je
vous dis aujourd'hui et je le dis à
gabrielal et je le dis à tout le
gouvernement je vous je vous explique
aujourd'hui tous les Français et la
majorité des Français sont derrière les
agriculteurs je dis majorit français
sont derrière les agriculteurs donc je
vais vous montrer le sondage regardez je
vais vous montrer le sondage regardez le
sondage de ce soir regardez 83 c'est la
première fois que Gill verd est du bon
côté du sondage première fois de sa vie
donc écoutez voyez ou pas donc les
Français sont derrière les agriculteurs
et je pense et là je vais penser à des
fins politiques parce que
ouais mine de rien aider les
agriculteurs ça ne pourra même vous
faire que du bien je vous le dis donc
pensez si vous pensez pasortunisme
exactement pensez par par opportunisme
aussi et mais aujourd'hui ce qui vivent
les agriculteurs et je vous jure on le
dit depuis moi ça fait 10 ans qu'on me
dit les
agriculteurs ils peuvent pas s'en sortir
et ben aujourd'hui ils ont ils ont rien
dit pendant 10 ans enfin ils ont rien
fait pendant 10 ans vous avez continué à
travailler parce que aujourd'hui les
mecs tu crois quoi quand ils bossent pas
un jour il le sent derrière ils sont
dans la merde donc qu'est-ce qu'il
faisaiit ils étaient énervés ils se
couchaient le soir il disaient
vraiment on se fout de notre gueule mais
bon le matin il y a le réveil qui sonne
et tu dois aller
bosser exactement ouis tu te dis tu es
obligé d'y aller et aujourd'hui à un
moment c'est vrai que un moment ils ont
raison de dire stop et je je vous jure
moi je c'est c'est un des métiers les
plus importants des importants plus
importants en France et aujourd'hui on
peut pas vous laisser crever je vous dis
on peut pas et il faut que toute la
France se mobilise que les médias se
mobilisent et que les gens c'est bien ce
que vous avez expliqué parce que les
gens qui nous regardent aussi le public
le grand public qui qui qui est pas au
courant de de plein de choses ils
doivent comprendre aussi ce soir
pourquoi je peux me permettre de de te
couper il faut avoir aussi en tête une
chose vous prenez l'exemple du blé le
blé il a baissé de 50 % de sa valeur par
rapport au pic qu'on a eu pendant la
guerre et pourtant votre paquet de pates
aujourd'hui qui avait augmenté pendant
la guerre en Ukraine benah il a pas
baissé de 50 % c'est ça c'est ça donc à
un moment donné il va peut-être falloir
qu'on fasse un point qu'on se dise qui
nous vole ou par l'argent et je pense
que ça c'est le premier problème pas
important ce qu' VI dire pas important
le blé il a baissé de 50 % pas les
pattes c'est comme
l'électricit ba le baril du pétrole 73
dollars l'essence toujours
donc les tax encore pour
l'écolog vous savez où ça part non c'est
les
distributeur c'est l'agroindustrie c'est
les distributeurs c'est tout le monde
c'est ça la lo protéger faire franise
qui nous dit on a perdu des boulangers
des artisans des agriculteurs des
soignants on parle jamais des petits
auto-entrepreneurs aussi c'est ça c que
je voulais dire je voulais dire ceux qui
on la puissance tout à l'heure je me
suis peut-être mal expliqué eux ils ont
la puissance d'avoir le leurs moyens de
locomotion pour bloquer les Français
mais tous les partisans qui en on r bol
qui se font taxer et qui peuvent rien
faire qui peuvent pas vivre de leur
travail mais non mais c'est tout le
monde c'est tout le monde sauf que ils
peuvent pas bloquer le pays donc un
moment donné j'aimerais bien que
j'aimerais bien que le gouvernement se
penche sur le prix du travail et dis
est-ce qu'on laisse crever tous les
boulangers les mecs les restaurateurs on
avait hier une jeune fille qui était
rest tout le monde crève en fait nous on
est privilégié je le redis encore mais à
un moment donné il faut faut se pencher
sur ce problème là en fait ce qui passe
on a lancé le hashtag nous sommes tous
agriculteurs donc pouvez mettre il faut
qu'il soit le plus le présent possible
ouais VO faire boug ches espère GAB
nouveau prier ministrea bouger les ches
très vite en tout cas Julien vous avez
toujours table ouverte ici si vous
voulez faire passer un message avec vous
d'autres amis agriculteurs vous êtes
toujours les bienvenus vous venez en
direct même si c'est pas prévu devant
l'émission et vous venez nous parler on
aura toujours un micro pour vous merci
d'accord bah c'est normal et on espère
que ça va aller là je pense que ça va
être ça va bouger ça va bouger je suis
confiant en tout cas voilà il faut que
vous gardiez l'espoir et je pense que ça
va bouger il faut une harmonisation des
charges a parce que vous vous avez des
charges énormes et les autres en Europe
ils ont des charges bien moindre que
vous donc la concurrence elle est
déloyale tout le temps pour vous sur
transposition des règles V qu'on nous
remet toujours une règle en plus une
mise au norme je pense aux éleveurs une
mise au norme EN PLUS allez on
réinvestit on rinvestit on remet de
l'argent on REM de l'argent un moment
donné on pe pas s' sortir les beau
parleurs la CGT fa tout ça les beau
parleurs bah oui parce que c'est ça
aussi faut dire est-ce queil y a des
gens derrière vous CGT F FDT les trucs
du transport ils sont pas derrière vous
c'est chacun pour sa gueule là on
devrait tous être ensemble en faitat
nousous on milite aujourd'hui pour que
tous les syndicats se regroupent il y a
une union al si ils sont venus moi j'ai
lancé un mouvement sur la 13 j'étais
seul j'ai fait un appel au syndicat les
syndicats sont venus ils nous ont
rejoint et moi je pense que tant qu'on
reste uni on est fort c'est ce que je
dis un moment donné il faut que tout le
monde se rapproche et que on se mette
autour d'une même table avec plaisir
merci dans un instant il Bertron des K
qui va venir nous rejoindre et oui c'est
un autre délire voilà bien le voir sur
un tracteur
celui-ci tout de suite
[Musique]